the worst possible things in the morning
to set their day up for failure what
would they be wake up and stay in bed
there are good reasons to stay in bed in
the morning but once those are completed
then staying in bed curtains drawn just
passively scrolling on social media
there are neurobiological data showing
that when you are upright you actually
are stimulating this area of the brain
called Locus ceruleus whereas when you
recline you actually are less alert and
the postural stuff is really bad too
this is so common now the c-shaped human
thing that it almost feels strange to be
upright I would say in bed so people are
on their phone they're not getting
enough light or they're trying to get
the sunlight through the window terrible
they're drinking coffee too early in the
day but it's mostly about the sort of
randomization of activities sort of
making a cup of coffee while texting
then they're scattering that in with
like a little bit of work but then
something hits that's stressful and
they're diverting their attention
they're sort of building in this
attention deficit like disorder they're
not being deliberate or intentional with
the things that they're doing they're
just allowing the morning to kind of
come and take them wherever the wind
blows that's right